the situation really i can't speak
without
cheers i'm sorry but i'm really sorry
for my country and nobody could expect
this really this is awfully awful things
they're bombing
they're bombing nikolai it's only
120 kilometers from odessa and it's
painful inside i i think that we need
more support for our people right now to
stand against this if if ukraine can
fall then next will be europe
that because for putin there is no
there is no stop he will be going
because he is a tyrant he's a tyrant and
he will go till the end until he's died
so until someone stop him
and
everything can happen we need to be
cautious about what he's saying because
what he's saying usually he's doing that
it's scary really and
many of my friends are there
many of my foreign partners
who were working in kiev they also they
i'm sorry guys
[Music]
they're trying to destroy our culture
now
the
bombing museums they're bombing
memorials they're bombing
people who are peaceful they are unarmed
they are not fighting they're just
protecting their land they are
protecting their freedom they are
protecting their language they are
protecting their children